Rossy, the Grammys are this weekend.
I know, I'll be watching.
I'm so excited because Trevor Noah's hosting
and I love Trevor Noah.
The best.
The best, and we're gonna get into it tomorrow
with Entertainment Tonight's Kevin Frazier.
He's a good friend of the show,
he's almost on weekly at this point
and one of the most heated categories is record of the year
and the field is just packed
with some of the best songs ever.
It is hard, you know, Dua Lipa, Billie Eilish,
Post Malone, Beyonce, the list goes on and on.
Savage, Megan Thee Stallion!
Body-ody.
So, Ross and I are starting a poll with our digital team.
Go to the Drew Barrymore Show Facebook page
and vote for who you think should win
and tomorrow, we'll all read the results
of that poll together.
Yeah, I was going through the list.
There are so many good songs.
Maybe it's just that we were all, like, stuck at home,
watching TV and listening to music,
but I think I know the words to all of those songs,
so we're gonna break it down tomorrow.
I think it was a really good year for songs.
Yeah.
Regardless.
Mm-hmm, toats.
All right, are you're gonna have your pick ready, Rossy?
Oh, yes.
I already think I have my pick,
but you have to tune in tomorrow to hear it.
Okay, perfect.
I'll be ready to go too.
All right, first up, we have got some groundbreaking news.
In Hollywood, Variety that reports that Apple TV Plus
has just inked a deal with Malala Yousafzai.
Apple has been partnering with everyone
from Steven Spielberg to Oprah, and now Malala.
She is a global champion for human rights,
girls' educations and I can't wait to see her passion
and perspective on Apple.
To think that somebody who was...
They tried to keep her quiet, they tried to kill her
and now she's gonna have this platform,
the most epic platform ever, what will she say now?
We'll all be listening.
She is incredible and I cannot wait to tune in.
She is here for a reason,
she's got something to say and we'll all be there for it.
And we've got some news about healthy fast food chain,
Chipotle.
Oh God, that sounds good, right?
There's one around the corner and you know,
Ross Matthews had been known to pop by
and now they have something very new.
Bustle reports they've teamed up with e.l.f. cosmetics
for a Chipotle new makeup line.
It comes with cute avocado applicators, called applicados.
(laughing)
No, but they should be called that
and then this eye shadow palette.
I'm seeing there's a guac inspired green,
maybe some shades of bean in there
and check out that fiery red lip shade,
it's a little spicy, a lip plumping gloss.
Okay, we love a collaboration.
Did you see this one coming?
This Chipotle and e.l.f. cosmetics.
You have it there, right?
I'm obsessed, I love this.
Oh my gosh, this is a makeup bag, literally!
Like a to go bag.
Yes!
Yeah, that's cute.
This is so fun and smart.
E.l.f. and Chipotle, I wanna eat you and wear you.
(laughing)
It gets me excited, like, other collabs you could have,
like, I know you love a filet of fish.
Do you think, like, Flower Beauty could do some sort of,
like, tartar face mask or something?
I mean, Flower Beauty and McDonald's anything.
Flower Beauty would love to collab with a company.
It's just, mm.
I'm trying on the spicy lip plumping.
Can you feel it?
It definitely has an essence of, like, spicy cinnamon.
I'm not mad at that.
I'm tingling.
(laughing)
Well, and after you chomp that Chipotle, guess what?
We've got the latest fitness trend
that is a burning up on Tik Tok!
GQ reports that the weighted hula hoop is great cardio
for your heart and a great workout for your core
and that's really important, the core.
Yeah, I have strong core values,
but not a strong core.
I didn't meet my core until I was, like, 42.
Yeah.
And the best part is you already know how to do it.
It's hula-hooping, it's like riding a bike,
the hips always remember
and they come in a variety of weights
and today, we're working out with the two pounder.
Two pounder hula...
Now, are you a good hula hooper in general?
Oh, Ross, I think you're about to find out.
Yeah.
(laughing)
I'm like Shakira, except my hips do lie.
I don't think I have the motion.
Okay, I...
This is...
Okay, ready?
This is how I hula hoop.
Go.
Okay, oh.
Wait, that's actually the most it's ever stayed on
in my life.
Hold on, let me, hold up.
The whole point is to keep it up above the...
Oh, oh, oh!
I can do it!
(screaming)
I didn't know I could do this, everybody!
Why can't I keep it up?
Do it a little higher.
I have, like, a nice fat roll, right here,
that's holding it up.
Oh my God, Ross,
you can hula hoop!
What?
Do you know how hard that is?
I didn't know I could do that until this very...
I love that we had this together,
thank you for joining.
Wow, that's fun!
By the way-
Oh, oh!
You guys, I've never been more of a natural
at anything in my entire life.
Drew, I didn't even know.
You always amaze me, Rossy.
How do you think I feel?
Oh my gosh!
(upbeat music)